hi Jane Cranston hi sheriff of
Oxfordshire being the returning officer
at the this election do hereby give
notice that the number of votes recorded
for each candidate said election is as
follows
Bennet Robin Frances Green Party 1864
one eight six four coil Laura Rose
Liberal Democrats 8485 eight four eight
five gray Patrick Hugo the Radical Party
392 three nine two how old
John Michael the Conservative Party
candidate thirty three thousand seven
hundred and forty nine three three seven
four nine Cavanaugh Oliver Labour Party
eleven thousand four hundred and fifty
five one one four five five Scott Tim
Owen
UK Independence Party you get one
thousand one hundred fifty four one one
five four the number of ballot papers
rejected was as follows
for want of official mark zero voting
for more than one candidate fourteen
writing or mark by which voter could be
identified one unmarked or void for void
for uncertainty 104 totalling 119 the
turnout was seven to six point three and
I do hereby declared John Michael Howell
is duly elected as the Member of
Parliament for the Henley constituency
well I'm not going to say an awful lot
because the political speech has been
made by by Ed Vaizey who always manages
to get in ahead of me no matter what
well what he does but let me thank the
High Sheriff as returning officer let me
also thank the staff and the police for
the excellent work that they have done
I'd like to thank my agent Alexander and
all the volunteers who have helped
during this campaign I've made an awful
lot of new friends and I'd also like to
thank Angie Patterson who has provided
some very special help to me throughout
throughout this campaign this dislike
just like aids campaigns the fourth time
that I had been elected starting at a
violation in 2008 and it is a great
privilege and an honor to serve the
Henry constituency I think the messages
that have already been already been
given are the correct messages for the
evening and I know that we've been here
for a long time and we still have
another count to do so I'm going to
finish there but thank you very much
you